welcome to this video playing Grand
Master lashy lashy from the US that's
Brian Smith right I had this guy before
and he lost a long Spanish so now he's
switching to the Kings Gambit and I'm
playing
my this this funky line that leads to
chaotic
play it's not the best line against the
king's Gambit but it is uh it is really
funny and uh it's it's it's it's
entertaining to play so hm what is this
exactly can I go E3
here and then take on F5 or or
H6 H6 he's going to go to
E6 that's
it's oh Bishop Bishop B4 going for a pin
Bishop B4 takes
D4 ah that looks crazy let's just play
that when you play this F5 business
against the Kings Gambit you know that
uh
you you you get a crazy position and uh
that is what we have
now so D4
[Music]
right
let's think about it just for a moment
yeah yeah but okay that's the only way
to make sense of my
[Music]
play yeah he probably has to play
something like Bishop somewhere D2 or B2
and this is this weird situation on the
king
side I always have this H6 move which if
the Knight moves I'm going to take
E4 okay so he's in Full full scale
attacking
mode um is there any use in no let's
just take take first think
later
okay so
um yeah he will have this check here and
Bishop B4 if I take the
Rook that's something that does not look
totally totally
right but check the checks are coming
immediately so it's he he does not even
need to
recapture
um so if I
take yeah I probably have to take D2
which is definitely not what I
[Music]
wanted check
so there's stuff coming
to F7 so trying to cover
that yeah it's this position is uh it's
just good for white I think he's got a
very strong
attack just with casts I mean there are
probably better moves
but even even fancy stuff like Rook A5
might be good Rook A5 to
E5 that's very strong actually I
think Rook
A5 B well just castles is
good if he does not want to play Fancy
[Music]
moves some message sent to me okay
someone thanks me for the videos that's
good
thanks um yeah what am I doing now E5 I
mean the other move looked crushing
already so I shouldn't
complain but I cannot I really don't
have a good move
[Music]
here Knight
E3 it's not helping P very
much Knight H7 at least is a blunder due
to Queen
H4 yeah I mean I can probably be
satisfied that I'm still on the board I
think Rook A5 just killed
me and then Rook
E5 I'm not saying I'm probably probably
still still almost lost
but maybe it could have been worth
Knight E3 is is something at
least
huh I'm not sure what his move
is probably
Castle I'm still I'm still having a
totally totally bad
King okay that's
interesting tending to take I have to I
have to take Knight H7
probably and now if I go here am I lost
or not I mean I'm covering F7 which is
pure
coincidential my knight here is covering
this
[Music]
Queen
G6
okay here
and put put the king put the King on
d8 yeah what a weird game but that's the
king's Gambit of course you have those
weird stuff all the
time he can probably put something on
the
defile I also have this chick
here and taking C4
H
yeah yeah that's just a kind of totally
random position where nobody knows
what's going
on yeah yeah yeah this this was
definitely possible if I take now here
he takes D4 and wins so I maybe have to
play a move like that I can give the
check but it's really just a number of
checks it's
not not really uh doing me me any
good okay I have to do that
[Music]
probably um okay so takes Queen H7 yeah
I'm probably lost
but ah wait I can maybe do
this time warning maybe I can do this a
he's got Knight D5 Knight D5 is strong
yeah Knight D5 saves him or saves him I
don't know Bishop F5 and things
is it would be but Knight D5 is just
killing the whole thing
unfortunately for
me um can I
play Bishop F5
[Music]
or no not
really
[Music]
it's really really just
lost anyway maybe I can irritate him
with a check Queen A3
check Queen A3
check
[Music]
check it's still not helping
right my Rook here
[Music]
check it's lost it's still
lost black resigned yeah that was a
totally totally random messy stuff but
okay with F5 you really initiate this
kind of stuff yeah and I saw that right
yeah Rook A5 kills me Rook it's
not nothing to do against this so but
this is also probably quite
good Rook h8 Queen
D3 check yeah and and long Castle it's
why is still winning and my king is just
just too bad it's just and here Knight
D5 seals the seals the deal yeah I I
really I just tried but cannot do much
so this means that probably around here
I'm
already I'm already playing uh wrong
moves um this is not so bad I mean this
this this what he played here isn't the
best line against this opening so I
should be in I should be able to play it
so Bishop takes his right it
seems and then play this
position yeah it's um it's it's really
really messy hard to say but um
it's as mentioned it's the kind of uh
line where you just have to want to just
want to have some fun with so um don't
worry so much about the results there
are better lines of course against the
king's Gambit okay I hope you enjoyed
this meth thanks for watching